greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
hims let me explain something to you had
a friend growing up Glenn since we were
kids he was losing his hair he did
everything spray paint
you know filled it in he did this he did
that and it didn't matter cuz 66% of men
start losing their hair by the age of 35
when you start to notice hair loss it's
too late you're like what's this little
circuit behind my head it's easy to keep
the hair you got that they replaced a
hand at your loss that's why guys turn
to weird solutions when they can turn to
medicine and science hems calm is a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men medical grade
solutions real doctors offer and
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your head nod herbal supplements
prescription solutions backed by science
so do me a favor
no walk with doctor visits save time by
going to four hems calm right now today
my listeners get a trial month of
everything you need for your hair for
just five hours today right now while
supplies last see the website for full
details this will cost hundreds if you
went to a doctor or pharmacy so go to
hims calm slash Joey
that's for hims fo r hims dot-com slash
Joey also brought to you by Fuji G's go
to Fuji sports right now if you're a fat
[ __ ] like me and a six I'm down on a
five no [ __ ] something you [ __ ]
together watching you okay you watch who
you talkin to
but anyway if you're thinking of a tough
Wally gee I'm a big guy so when I'm on
top and they're my god they're pulling
their [ __ ] pulling that falling then
pulling my sleeve to try to get me
across they can't do it cuz I got a Fuji
[ __ ] me go to Fuji Sports calm right
now
pick out a [ __ ] gear hopefully a
super righto that's the best gear they
got in my mind and you get 15% off is
depressed in church that's how we're
rolling it tonight
check that [ __ ] meal leak the
Churchill was happen now it's Monday
morning the 12th of the 30
it really doesn't matter I'm very
excited to announce this to guests we've
been talking about it for a while my
main man mr. Yoel Romero number one
contender in the world fighting for the
championship June 8th and [ __ ]
Chicago to Windy City thank you for
coming to the show and I said well buddy
they'd show me money
thank you so much my pleasure thank you
a dolly how you doing brother
I'm doing gum I'm pumped up this is a
being in a room with two Cubans like I'm
right I think I feel like I'm ready to
go fight if I have listen I'm not and
I'm a guy I don't you know I watch it
I'm a fan so what I wanted to do was
leave it to the professionals tomorrow
what I want to do it yo is to ask him
you know when you when you look at you
all going to the ring you see this
superhuman dark-skinned kid that you're
scared of but this is not what this is
about
tonight we're gonna get to know who the
hell Yoel Romero is who's your gang a
hero Romero being a compiled nobody
nothing
now see ya and by the moon with the -
you have been at the real Yamaha leading
mundo who know some orange soda in a
great day a crea gamma dhaula kuan being
with day in sabato
or en doha you er $1 water wonderful oda
he was raised like any other cublas and
he was raised you know poor no shoes
playing in the [ __ ] dirt you know the
humble you know the home brew life like
every every every kid in cuba the center
for the every kid kids kid in cuba you
know are not different for the kid in
Cuba I am an alum again I say all my
life in the city you know I stayed with
him a people you know and the shoes
ruining I I playing baseball
no shoes I played the ball you know with
my friend in Cuba
very humble you know no no no no problem
for that for the for the color for the
for the see the people's blogs the
people I know everybody is the same
you know everybody take it the same
water everybody drink the same water
when the playing baseball you know this
is amazing time that's it what the
people needed the people need a little
the people they've been there for this
for this for this time the people needed
remember the time this time is a big the
most important no no no problem no no no
matter what what the people is see you
having more morning about him no there's
no important the most important is the
relationship you know more than
everybody together everybody playing the
same play and the same emotion the same
time this is this is amazing time how
many brothers do you have
I have a three sister and four brothers
and your father did one Cuba yeah my
father think you know what is he do a
look at last year oh my father is a
boxing boxing I'm at a bar scene yeah I
say is it number trees and they in Cuba
and the national team your father
yeah yeah no but what does he do for a
living now can look at yeah that's not
the action box El Morocco said outside I
was young and I'm standing national team
the the Cuban Olympic Center you know so
he wants the only picks - no no he no go
to their Limpy he's the number three in
Cuba the number three incident oh yeah
magnifico CRN's Magnifico boxes
everybody know they the guy is the
number one is the Besson and this
division and Canseco me
Costigan was the amazing amazing guy is
the number one the number two is a but
not the comic shop in the world - and
the number three is my father you know
but is maybe they did the theater Osama
know - I remember going to see that
number on over and
there are lines of funnel how old were
you when you first boxed what I'm sorry
you
you know temper disassemble all the time
I want to make it the books of him by my
friend wanna you know my face another
his boxing his he's a very hot as Paul I
don't wanna you you you follow my
footsteps you know see my my way you
know I don't want you you follow my way
you can you can do another another spoil
and now and one coach you for worsening
seen me you say you have a talent for
Wesley you know but I am try on the
baseball to and trying them in many
sport but finally I I make a wrestling
you know this cozy no no come you you
family making boxing and wrestling you
have a telephone for wrestling to and
that's what I Megan Wesley you know so
you spell it wrestling and cube without
in Cuba's there a high school Kauai call
or hate the more I see and cry and Cuba
the system the name for the suggesting
is that parameter system you know it's a
terrible pyramid system you know you see
tomoko-san a mobile army and don't say
for sure moving it's a very good system
um don't alone in don't let the kid make
it at the sport very being controlling
something Horning sorry right they get
you when you're young yeah when the kid
is very job like a like in the beginning
I have eight years old you know you
started when you know Daniel trying
Olympus evolution and then vamos
opponent when you get older be that the
real goes up against come away like it's
lo que pasa who today Bank on track I'm
away or sees an associate emmab Romero
to me she I say a were not already value
padre de casa
it was a cheetah Hernando Vesuvian the
car
in the I play a later you can complete a
national international you know like
this and how did you get when you were
18 what was your life like well Duke an
alias your chocolate when I have 18
years a stay in the Union national team
I stay in the national team my life is a
it's different when I have a you know
but no no no no that my life in chain
little by little you know now Isamu
charming cool you don't suffer so much
I'm like ooh it was a lot of people
starving for you but they give you a
certain amount of eggs every month and a
certain amount of milk because you were
a wrestler did you get more food not
much comida si Claro Claro Claro yeah I
say not to pull my moving Jenny say como
being sick oh my they have nothing to
nothing soon I think wow yeah so they
treat you a little better they give you
a little bit why is like my uncle I'm
sorry but though my uncle told me you
only time it deal me told me that my
cousin's a key whatever he goes they
live like kings in Cuba that they don't
look like everybody else carry on the
whole killing thing cool saying that my
son which I'm really star say sorry not
everybody I am so the athlete has
priority they give you milk on Lecce say
where will they give you eggs Daria
well I can't can you can you explain why
like why in in Cuba like in these small
countries is it so important like why do
they play such a huge importance on on
them getting the best and and like
giving them special treatment like it
was
like what like what like what is it
about cute like why in Cuba like it
seems like there's something about I
guess it's a it's a tough country to
live in a lot of people have certain
feelings about that country like why why
do they take such a big importance on
baseball's huge readily why is that such
a huge thing there I look at they get it
he wants to ask you love airport day why
is it so important in Cuba okay ain't an
important thing and cool
okay no every teacher sent I'm gonna go
look two questions okay um I think the
talent God give the talented people and
kill it now now you can go Cuba and you
can see many talent because I think
that's what I thinking I think God did
the Italian for the for the sport in
Cuba before the people you know right
now the last time when I say in queue I
see many people kissing Malenko but I
said go get te booty you know no opera
time SNC teman the another point is the
system with the key were happy for them
for this poll you know is Magnifico
Magnifico chicken this is very very to
have it down to a son cccc and creating
Magnifico a system and i said the pod
now and you're only see the when I was a
kid I was growing up and I met these
guys from the oh I like a lotta dough
you're not gonna tell her and see you
don't you okay
your policy I you look you may be
helping co-op a you the Pina Rhonda man
down GUI GUI they would send you the
train at these diets not this is true
you know but this is the normal is for
and the line and apparently spawn in the
war you know because
United State taking for example check
out a racing team take out the people
and and send a the team for the Russia
for the two or three moon this is every
country do it is you know every con to
do this because I wanted a more sparing
I want more like a co-op against
different people look yeah but yo creo
que que okay licencia and they get the
booty top one or say I went oh yep okay
yellow your dormancy in a commode on
being a gone on a personal errand gently
it so getting on the corner I have to
coin for example you take a three or
four five people in Brazil he's a four
or five people for you take a three
three play very good football soccer
that's a head talent God give the
attorney for the soccer you know so you
take three people five people ten people
for Jamaica for their for the for the
truck believe me maybe five six make it
good
very good ugly that says that the God
gives you talent you know I mean look
what the the baseball you know look at
what what Cubans have done I mean even
before Castro they would go down there
for spring training did you know that
they're like players will go to Cuba to
play against Cuban players to get some
good in the summer listen what I don't
want it when I looked out for me though
in the offseason that belonged I say I'm
cool to Train no because they wanted
that you know metal sharpens metal bro
right so they will go down there to
Train now the other there's another side
to this coin
Yoel then a lot of people don't
understand I think you
in these countries we don't have as many
distractions or to muchas muchas plants
are solid there seemed no computer or no
no I maintain is totally training
training the totally training so Phi
training student you go to the school
return for the house or returning for
the for the for the room and you took at
the foot and later you twenty again I
get to time your training in the day
well it's depend they're all you know
what they're there for the other for
them for the June you know and I've been
the end of I'm ending it up the age the
age you know is dependent dependent for
the a shop did you live at the pyramid
too long being a pyramid she she
wouldn't would be a yahoo know you go to
the house only soldering today's
Saturday and Sunday and you go baffle
day for them for the school you know
take ticket hours and equality lunes
argument you know interns intern hours
our classes typically and then because
you were a wrestler no service not an
off week they go Ally has no no no gone
okay now wrestler see you know Goffe
arms abysmally De Luca equal get out -
how old were you when you said that said
no more Cuba training when I have it 32
33 years why because I want to know more
another possibility more best life for
my family you know I want to make it a
MMA I you know I dream for my life for
my for my family you know I I want to do
they did you know did you know can make
it as you have seen you you know K you
know can make it you have make it that
you have seen Keira see you wanted to be
say see you wanna see you wanna stay in
good 11 in the war and then you want to
do something you didn't go you know you
don't need to stay in this play because
this place is the same is the guy said
no mean mata Hanuman one of him to
necesita but deal on the Ptolemy whole
la mejora beyond the best option option
free you know the best option is out the
Cuba you know in Cuban Omega Omega MMA
you know it could indicate that I say
Camino today keep the triceps when you
take in the travel they'll look at a
they look at there are supposedly Isis
when you so when you want Cuba when did
you see everybody how did you see MMA
the first time well I I am you know in
corner hit that way and MMA right they
say that they steal the signal urania I
see that then they all school for MMA
you know and there is a body to D Valley
told Time Inc honestly I'm our Ultimate
Fighter you know and okay yourself
aliasing contemporary tying up to thank
ya they said you were watching all the
see how are you watching it you think AB
Ania no and also chef redress imprint
and sorry Sofia heat on CD - sorry
gente que vivió persona convenient the
coolest a getting along a cool it's a
wrong in CD so people would go on do you
know equal know your yeah so Wow when
you saw everybody said I think I can do
this I can do is no so momentum your
parser a so you porcelain or digital
really you thought that way yeah so
you're 32 years old what do you do
Gallagher do awesome
the idea to defeat them what did you do
over there and talk to somebody
yeah yeah me me me tiempo para the
middle mr. Zito said maybe for like the
cool
Thomas icc own so once you made the
decision you told your wife you couldn't
say nothing silly and I'm gonna get idea
persona uncool episode I mean we
officially KKK sorry I said well yeah
that's a little yes he he says I took to
somebody you know especial people when I
have a confidence in people lovers come
visit people you know and say that's
what I need to do for my life for your
life for the life of my people for my
family um maybe I maybe I maybe the most
exciting for you major triumphant you
maybe you will triumph it maybe I try I
try a triumphant maybe do it maybe no
but by the way i holla we doing an
intent on it then they say to me please
I'm in tune input no matter why would I
do CIA training like a crazy boy I said
ok thing like I said pull over at miss
when you know Sarah bloom in awake a
career you were gonna do whatever it
took to achieve your dreams
do we wrestle ok you I said I said come
PLC enter now come on look say and don't
say you went to Germany to wrestle and
you stay ok Sally gonna keep on a Chanel
I go with the National just a different
cue before the Grand Prix's in Germany
lap Cena Cena and the city for lights in
Germany and when I finished in the
tournament and win the tournament the
Grand Prince I win and they say ok I
called my brother my my my little
brother is saying your money leaving you
boksoon I call him and say that's at the
time I never want to go out for tea when
you say for sure yeah for sure
okay uncle my brother I know I know go
back killer and I make it and generally
have a wrestling mmm competition for the
Bundesliga season Germany Bundesliga
they McGee I continued wrestling you
know and one day I see competition for
every way and say when I go I go I no no
no no training no never in my life I 20
but I fight I fight I win you ain't
continued does it and from Germany how
long did you stay in Germany policies
years six years you know you get the
apple butter you're not there to reunite
with your family how long did it take
you by name in years 11 years without
your wife and your children no no no no
my mommy
tengo tres hijo I have a tricky but my
son is thinking key where this is
different amount right you know no come
on really Seco Mia you know right now
how long did it take you is it - Senor
our little see ya - come over lucky
you're gonna change your money you know
oh yeah you better in Germany so she's
German sea iguana Alomar
two German cubed leaf so can't can you
guys talk about like do you feel trapped
in Cuba because like you hear these
stories about people leaving Cuba and it
doesn't to me it doesn't seem like you
don't like cube it seems like you have a
lot of love for Cuba but let's see like
what what the emotion is to like to have
to want to leave you have so much love
for but you have to get out
I love Cuba ya know I have I have a
passion I have a love they really love
for my country but you know see you ask
the people when the people go for the
for the Exeter for many excellent the
war when the people go out for the
country you you ask for the people you
love you you you country everybody say I
love my country you know I never hear
nobody say I not love my country
this is different I love my people I
love my country I love the people when I
when I when I play with me when they
aren't kid you know I love I continue
because when I go Cuba right now when I
go when I now I go about Cuba I cry I
cry because I haven't you know Sandman
is uh come on it's hearty yeah you know
many history many history you know you
never forget this because is your sense
see you say the people know you see
somebody saying I love my country they
remember I'll see you this is you you do
you know enough United to learn ah you
do you know come on Sadie say so today
you're nothing you're any man if you
don't love your country you don't love
the country United now you know hey I
think I don't know at least for me I
think it's different I love America but
whenever I hear stories about people
maybe it's not Cuban maybe it's other
countries I can tell you must be really
torn like
kitty do you think you're gonna leave
keyboard you like I'm I'll never leave
Cuba we know to consolidate never never
- no - gnosis do they say boy I reveal
when you born do you think like this I
burn here I did hear a house in the same
house because you burn and you see left
and you see right you see your mama you
see you dad you see your sister you see
your brother you see you family and you
say this is my my kingdom this is only
what I need and it's used in your life
using and you mind only you thinking are
you boring here I dig here with my
people you know thinking you wanna go
out another house you think of this
later and yes but not the same time it
doesn't that does it the same whatever
happening in the life of the people when
you come as a second sir when you grow
when you grow and now you see the life
the life push you life and now you need
push you need to push your life tonight
push you you need to put your life for
better you know better and better
because that's the that's the way you
know and Tosun is a seat of morocco like
I saw at the party now you need to move
the house for the house that you family
the youth whether you mow you down
because now you you have a woman and now
you have it that you re see you have a
you do have a kit you need it you need
to move but you need a move because you
wanted more better for your kids not for
you for your kids for your family and
don't say you have to technique my know
condo to sala de la casa I wonder you go
out of the houses you family to you that
you mom and you daddy
you you know thing about another house
you go out maybe another country another
city another language another culture
edition but you need to go no matter
what but you need to go yes
you were stuck in Cuba bro guitars are
encore you had nowhere to go
even though you were loved you have your
family there yeah you want more you want
[ __ ] more when they bit when that's
the way I talking that's what I say when
the life push you you need to push you
the pushing the life see la vida tempura
two important are you see lamp or see la
Vida not a condo located Creek at Emory
say over okay to necesita para holly how
to Familia baraja Tim Mahal to delicous
a little color [ __ ] on the thing
yeah so what he saying is him if white
pushes you you gotta [ __ ] push back
you know we get stucked at our own
[ __ ] mud sorrow and you have to go to
where you could grow you know and we've
all been through the you know this is a
situation of it's called sacrifice we've
spoken about this show a thousand times
you know I have a twenty seven-year-old
daughter have no conversation with it
wants me every [ __ ] day but guess
what I was going nowhere in Boulder I
wanted to be a [ __ ] he always will
remember do we seeked it and just a
different matter
my mom did what you did you know they're
monitoring who I was born she took me
back my sister was still in school he
said I got to know whether she wanted to
stay with a grandmother and that summer
Castro said no see yes this that and
next thing you know my sister
grew up in Cuba she didn't have the same
opportunities I had do I live with that
[ __ ] guilt every [ __ ] day you know
but it's upon your theory and whenever I
watch you fight your parents women
mother when you develop a lot when I
watch you if I can fight because it's
like I know where you're coming from
your settlement with Iranian intend your
sister free mentor do you think on a
said your sets off remained over dude I
am stirring okay Tom unload in
Lackawanna lieutenant you know how many
Cubans left their [ __ ] loved ones
behind yeah but not that it'll leave him
behind like I'm leaving you behind I
left you behind because I want to do
something better with my life that's
what you want to do something better
with your life so title Amalia they're
mighty thing at first MMA fight that out
there yeah the first ones a cow or a cow
okay now calm and don't say how many
amateur fights did you have no no do
anything whenever nano average oh no you
went right into [ __ ] MMAC you needed
money no time to [ __ ] around when I go
and said you know can do it in comedy
because you have a olympian world
championship background you know can do
amitin see what yeah you need to go to
professional fighting so oh my god and I
said okay go that's that I never do a
mother I never can on her name I never
remember train and then play I go to
fight so you took a couple tools you had
from the house with a couple Indian
daughter you're still learning that's a
that's a what I say the people might me
guess I'm gonna donate to terrible in
the end though didn't you drop a ninepin
indeed okay simply way more total via up
in there it's always good to learn
something every [ __ ] day yeah the
same way by Deborah netted the other
mother good last day you stopped
learning is the day you [ __ ] die
tiene que tienen la mente como si
aggregated oh I meant a communion you
have to have a mind like a child in many
ways like a sponge
you know Lee's getting into comedy right
now and I called him last night and this
morning to explain to him that he's
living this life now that he's he's
never done this before he's doing
stand-up comedy you know and I told them
no matter where this goes no matter
where this takes you this is this
journey that you're doing it's gonna
open up your eyes even if you don't stay
a comic you're still gonna do something
you know and that's what I talk about in
this podcast every day that sometimes
you want your life to change but you
don't know how to [ __ ] change it you
gotta make a move you gotta make a move
and that's why I got the utmost respect
for these guys I had an opportunity that
I could have been in him I could have
been in his [ __ ] neighbor you play us
a busy no clue your honor pretend and go
up yo when my mother died I [ __ ]
threw my life away but bent the end you
don't in they won't allow either yeah
but Allah oh he para and it was like
Cuban upbringing it was what I learned
from a Cuban house we were watching
videos before this we were getting fired
up and we're watching wall on gold
videos yes lady came run and he was
calling her a G that she's the type of
woman that she has a beef she sends the
Sun to go down there and kill the
[ __ ] dude that was the mentality and
Cuba I'm entirely tinta him we play for
keeps one do I uh one when the or
sellout good pop god I don't go there to
[ __ ] around to the giggle that was what
was given to me from the Cuban side that
was too sad la la Montagna your simpler
mentality then then that people can be
able to buy a key I'm Italian eyes a
little different we play harder you
don't saying we ain't got time to be on
the [ __ ] phone he who on don't know
you're doing this game without us even
though our goal and he does from Sonia
guitar Holly oh yes in the law it also
mean you know becoming who I became a
common contour socket or your free play
so when will all that man this are going
to jail and all that I still became a
[ __ ]
and it wasn't because I was better than
a buddy I'm gonna frame I hope they're
gone Karolina
look I'm insane ya don't have what I
learned as a young man as a Cuban the
thing is the lessons my mother instilled
in me you know before the show we're
talking about knowing up I thought about
that cos allow that means don't come to
this house hit yeah like if you throw
two punches and the kid for those three
punches you came home hit in a Cuban
house that's not allowed
that's not even [ __ ] comprehended even
if you have to go back and hit him with
a [ __ ] chair at least you didn't stay
hit that mentality is a [ __ ] crazy
mentality but it works for me you know
we were listening to music and he said
to me that I was old school yeah he goes
Joey's old school and he he was breaking
my heart saying that this doesn't even
exist in Cuba no morning then now it's
reggaeton and rap music yeah yeah I see
Mike I attack the f-4s here plays heavy
metal guitar the whole [ __ ] deal I'm
like what the [ __ ] happened so it's uh
it's it's so six amateur fights when all
of they are more where'd you go first
strike for so these rifles don't we the
precise without malice hey okay I'm Alan
big man me I'm more straight from
Germany you want to strike force see
buddy let's try a Philly right tourist
rifles I am gonna be in the freezing
like skunk are you Adam in oh yeah let
me say capital o and Raphael Raphael
fire that way sitting
let me tell you something I said that's
what I say everything you let you need a
C+ no [ __ ] D I lose but but I see
everything positive do you know what
because I win this fight the next you
know who it is
whether the next fight Sanderson
Sanderson is the champion stifles right
eye is it you know what happens and I
fight with this guy I know that's it and
I know how they spin it for the differ
for this fight I say thank God I lose at
this fight because I
I've got the fight with the it making me
destroying me
maybe I threw in sending some you got
rid of me
no kidding it tn8 a tower I said Walker
didn't up I'm gonna tell him we'll just
put in see I didn't otama hole into Aria
you're witnessing a Parisian you had no
experience no me I used to kill you see
Herrera in the [ __ ] up the series ok
mediate on a Monday when I yeah they
play made me wonder us a bit but I'm
Anna
Gracia do put it
thank God is if you wanna beat Raphael
faiza you would have had a fighter with
no experience see did you find out the
Raphael failure no does it play and pass
a para para UFC to us on your simple yet
porque tu eres in here Nick wey Oh II do
know your family go do yours
como siempre Dios is ok kkkkk UFC be an
RSM me e ok for me but I made up la
única ballet Angus rifles the present I
don't mess at the plane they separatist
rifles you see tomorrow
Tomas rifles even today USA kkona kkona
kkona pac-10 neck surgery el la Penna
soon your body before you were you you
have seething ok en la pared up again
look at this happy in a banana for
knockout
yeah little Macedo we are gonna say
sorry co-op or the opinion Uwe Seeler
you okay you're the power do only
powerless it'll clean yo loca home this
is so you got knocked out what we
haven't you have neck surgery and this
UFC still signed you and they paid for
the surgery
yes yes I do look awesome yeah I do a
kimono science empanada Cooper and ami
the patella Sylvia I'm sorry book a food
processor to the processing processor
where they put a on opening Joe
solamente Appa Rao
America presume cuatro meses
operation was four months full moons are
they playing a poker missing person
Turner okay no my men to say I won't
menu but I said I call it a figure
usually they even start brush I left the
four months but don't jab you hidden
okay question upon yeah I said did you
go snoop on Hamilton's okay no point
Ellis in the co-stars in the bouquet
jewelry shows telling me from India
do you know petabyte Oberlin you know
say yeah the present the deliberation
the program a parent present ricotta my
see a plug-in percent rounder play robot
amazing
Alice see they missing forget us email
mobile monopoly trap the seven months
from your surgery
yeah next surgery seeing the UFC called
you for your first fight scene and who
was it against Glee for a start
okay meet up we met up in Illinois to
see your team in a banana not even you
like the [ __ ] on the undercard on ly c
FX [ __ ] three your feet up and went
up in there I don't she ee you okay
gave me a in Nakano you're not that well
so you got the lot colors then I yeah
see yeah yeah I bet it all [ __ ] start
after that see yet I won't get to go do
no more knit and you still fix the Cuba
you would love to go back to Cuba
someday I might I might add whatta ya
mean what ibogaine
take one and who's left in Cuba your
father adding me holding my time I saw
my father and my mom sees Tim Brothers
things and they're all there and my
eastery your history yeah my a stirring
okay okay okay I'm getting what I grew
up just see you seeing the one you see
wasn't a traitor but a war so even
though that you are the QB still making
history for Cuban Jim is still in yard
and whatnot you're a bad [ __ ]
sir thank you so much a soldier
that's time see you son boy now let me
ask you a question here cuz I want to
ask you more questions about cubelets
stuff like that
did you ever meet Fidel what did you
ever wanna see taffy that CWC na na mano
Laura's enemy no [ __ ]
see you around England and cool how old
were you
20 22 years old that had you were you
already like a big-time wrestler in Cuba
at 22 yeah yeah yeah yeah you had
already been filled with Pixar 22 yeah
no [ __ ] yeah
at 22 you already yeah Jenny Jenny see
you were already like [ __ ] me yeah
yeah champion 2 1 2010 8 21 years old
Olympic rocking chair 20 years old
Jesus Christ I remember uncut and when I
win the World Championship in Ankara I
have a 21 years old is a 199 him in
wasn't the non-genuine the one day
company the moon the uneven color but
yeah we all are the world medals at them
yeah and you know in this year
Kohi prada and you know entire show in
Tehran Kohi bronze a young Latino hero
you know what him because he named mm
zipper
yeah he's assuming that I don't miss ya
Day 2007 that's [ __ ] amazing
wonderful girl Sadie I don't know
what'd he say to you when he met you
congratulations oh yeah I is a he
congratulations your yeah I am
everybody know the people he know me you
know he know he know what I say is the
truth I am for that for that for them
for their for their for all sport he was
formidable apetito
for all the athletes so there are other
akiva for many years I am stay every
time the most best thing is for for all
ugly stinky man yo let's outsider
yeah along with the boxers and what else
is big in Cuba baseball boxing the most
important is the national sport in Key
West baseball baseball baseball yeah
another lovely in your family play
baseball
no no yeah pretty much yeah bellowed up
at all and to be a baseball pitch pocket
ah that's the that's the [ __ ] home
ground that's where God makes him he
makes a lot of them once I save you Joe
when you were growing up because you
said to me that Cuba has changed a lot
when did it start changing in your eyes
you don't mind when I met when I met my
cousins it was maybe eight years ago and
my song remains the Led Zeppelin came on
on the [ __ ] when we were in Kansas
that song stay where they haven't
assumed I'm any kind of came up and they
were singing him in Spanish yeah
emergency any liberals there how did you
get that how did you hear this it may be
I don't care when people in the
neighborhood a guy in the neighbor had a
cassette a Led Zeppelin if you like
Indian are casa it's not like that no no
no no is that what it used to mean you
remember it like that yeah you know
today there's no no I we we come upon
you're doing what into you what do you
mine you know that brows he said it's a
cosa pero or in Kolkata for música so he
must go wrap the AC so if I'm driving
down the street and cube the government
all say nothing no internet still no no
I Internet Gloria GI all the reason to
that seeing a guru Laura intern Sen Tian
Kuo CIA CIA
see lieutenant position in Loris I don't
see I ain't any lie does the same thing
your family have a computer seems from
the idea so your family's doing good no
problems or as hell I thank you God I
thank you God the God beat me they put
it in a opportunity for thee for the
help my prominent my family stake I say
thank you God you know Joell like I told
you when I met you earlier that will
never like I hadn't really get ready for
this like because your mother what you
were doing at my pot a lot could they go
poking my bunghole
you're so comical how I'm a you're very
funny guy look at me
I don't think oh I have a little bit of
sadness in my heart you thinking puppies
pickle there homeostasis sadness in
Spanish please Tessa is no more never
because you have aa man but I have one
athlete Tessa that like I feel guilty at
times but at the same time she has to
walk more I always feel something it's
no more I can I can't understand you
because that's a happen for me to do
diamond tangled it is a well when you
when you on the to the heart chakra
caused us let it leave [ __ ] you owe you
my freedom of choice on your butt is
numb all I remember of cube is a [ __ ]
beat by this no matter because does is
you know the easterly the moistest
in the Bible yes nothing is the same is
the same myself where Moses he don't
remember nothing about the family you go
you leave the Cuban when you have a
three years old by Moises
leave the moment take it the moistest
and put in the moisture and there and
then
in Egypt Iran and Egypt yeah Moses
Taniya circling on you
it was a gyro why is but inside in the
Indian dispute in the end miss Alma and
the soul in the so did annoy see he
loved when the people you the people
he's the same well what's the story
it's a story of Moses his the Jews were
slaves in Egypt his mother I think had a
baby with the king right yeah the
Pharaoh and that wouldn't be allowed so
the mother put him in a little wee
little baby care to put him down the
Nile River and they go he got adopted by
the Pharaoh's family and he had a
brother but uh but when he got older and
he escaped he escaped like the burning
board he found the burning bush and I
think I think he he got in trouble
because he he said that he stopped at an
Egyptian guard from hitting a Jewish
slave so he so that's but he always knew
even though he was raised as an Egyptian
royalty he couldn't let that happen
okay ke ke kicking the hip Tatar okay on
Don Julio
oh he's Randy done yes one man she's a
good soul he knew you yeah she seemed to
my focus on console monitoring moto but
a member gets in T I guess I hinted at
Connolly's regarding you know yes LOL
mokh adiposity the center to treat a okc
antic a quality Lohara I do I don't feel
terrible
yes I feel I feel terrible because I
know that you're celibate when are your
you know I had my own [ __ ] setbacks
like when I talked to my sister on the
phone you know how I don't know what to
say that
no secular syllabus I cannot hear oh no
I don't know what to talk to because I
never really met her and I like her life
her mother left and told I was coming
back sometime
no sorry sometime you don't need to say
nothing because that's all I'm asking me
but our two lovers you know Tilly para
casi libera NOS i your idea then they
get a target in a case hindi yes then
the point I said to to me I won't allow
children in our case in the Prophet
Enoch Assembly did Akira Sala oka was
hold a 5555 haven't seen you flopping me
I am my own man okay to my own and don't
say to like I had to put cincuenta
source on you're not out a song no you
know then get tuned up way to person 20s
on you know I 53 years photo suppose in
2009 eternal Ezekiel T Hamilton right
angle to two-person contest and you know
down south to known as I see Tennessee
Solana to necesitas
our a celebratory attempt okay - no I -
that's it that's it so I shouldn't feel
guilty
yeah should your [ __ ] thought I always
felt guilty I just really do it sir I
never talked about on the podcast as
never really came up before and that's
that's why whenever I'm around like an
85 when I really learned the pain and
what was going on in Cuba it just
[ __ ] killed me I didn't know that you
lived on three eggs a month I didn't
know yeah you know they automata FA from
the same filter [ __ ] a month I didn't
know these things John Doyle you know
sorry an area - cool
I thought Cuba was a [ __ ] party I
didn't know you have approached us with
a means to a mucho you know sadness you
know I'm saying yeah I had no idea until
I do met those people in 85 you know
when I was growing up everybody hated
[ __ ] Fidel
when you attack the end when I was
growing up you couldn't even mention
[ __ ] Fidel you didn't City elope or
the NESC the local pot said that they
don't see mind you know and then over
the years like here like in Cuba it
slowed down a little bit uh it's more
accepting Lackawanna but I had the same
you know in Kyoto or they do know they
get together and talk about Fidel all
[ __ ] day long
it didn't end all that that really well
and go ah it's too late you're in the
United States well you know that and the
humans that's the most the most strong
within the human having inside the
spirits the people and the human wanna
lose no one I forget then in the past
you know you need to say common sense if
I do not forgive that you need to forget
the people you know you need to forget
and forget to necessitous of bedad ever
do not you know forgive and forget you
know because you know you develop or
even may I said all you know I know that
you know so lapel I had to tell somebody
that they cuando no do you own in your
heart don't anger in your heart you're
not gonna grow you know you're not gonna
grow until you let that [ __ ] go and
that's what happened with me put banged
in your towel I'll tell you oh my house
God do we take the child's mother you
know I was raised Catholic boy yo creo
yoga hot yoga moon yes uniform artists
are KKK no CMOS Brunel a una trying
ratio do memory and then yes yamazaki
supports across
in Acadia stomatology sumo sumo know
sort of Entomology only the paternal a
parameter no I do beg is apparently I am
worried una Casa Loma
maintain Mauricio month the police are
angry sink a to a sermon and then
but is sometimes nice young is no money
famous a person I was young and no math
to my Kotaro
okay I got a man on the road they they
really are getting along then gently
okay take a dose what I saw in resume is
no man and then come to me and Omarosa
no KK K I said yeah yeah guy a cool over
I saw Tommy and the Salian is curious
let me ask you this last question that's
it brother
a dhow that's it you fight for the
championship
thank you God yes thank you John yes how
do you feel I feel blessed I feel it
ready
I say yours
I say God thank you for this opportunity
thank you for giving me this talent
give me you too much Western anything
commander e como con con mucho more econ
control control Ilana I said Tessa
look at where I keep okay - maputo Yi J
Omega T how are you gonna be different
this time for will occur are you gonna
be different this time
another morning a lot of mugginess Yogi
and Tina kept ions in I didn't get by
but I make it look awesome
I gotta pay the see with you haven't
something I don't you see get inside a
store didn't give I just want to know
but I can't get Lagasse
to cashier tarrying about this fight you
ready yeah yeah healthy no I was gonna
take you to make weight you see you guys
are taking the e put on oh boy look at
her I wanted him to make weight so we
got to start now
sorry different you know every day is
different yesterday's pero con field you
you can't say yeah
Boyet an economist in tow no como mi
siento Roberta Morgana are a machine for
a machine to
siento get to pass out our about you
don't 208 pounds
yeah actually you walk around and that's
very basically walks around it yeah
that's not bad
Oh to wait and you're already working
out again yes you started working out
already you know look at him he never
stops working out but okay what do you
what happens to you because you talk
about that first loss and how are you
looking back you're happy about it
do you take losses now a little bit more
seriously because because of people like
Joey who like you out you're having it
you have more more you've more than fans
like we talked about we have family you
have cube you have the Cuban people
behind you do you take that loss to
Whittaker like more seriously do you
think than other fighters take losses la
padilla contra Whitaker cool youth
rebellion or the father is the father
karate to tell parties but to familiar
people who wanna you fight for
everything involved that's the type of
guy you are when you lose do you take a
fight that seriously or do you look up
and say thank you God forgive me a lot
but Tony another day to [ __ ] live and
[ __ ] I'll be back he is like this just
like that that's the attitude you gotta
take I saw him right afterwards he had
his wife his daughter hand in hand
they're all walking together and I look
for him are you okay but I'm fine I'm
great
and look that was that the first time I
received fired that okay with with
everything I said you sure he goes
everything is great don't work you have
a good attitude you up and that's
because they're thinking your humble
beginnings thinking that's that's why
you have a lot they took it again it
it's a lot of ways and you want to do
clear thing Lou ten it's something a
pride sometimes it's a little giddy as
he do to holiday meal Teterboro get to
build okay I mean what they did yeah I
have the same attitude
it's uh it's very powerful you know I'm
not gonna stop I'm a work talking I head
together it may I'm gonna pull us a lot
at one or me some a popping when I see a
naked woman might dig
don't get hard you tell me I can't do
something that's on my dick gets hard
you understand me that's when I can't
sleep at night and that's what I have
that you have that it's when they can't
tell you you can't do something yeah
that's a [ __ ] beautiful feeling yeah
listen brother I wanna do some shout
outs real quick and we'll get you the
[ __ ] are you hungry oh yeah
salads only just salads that [ __ ] I got
John Weight Watchers tonight chicken
breast and salad that's it if I give you
a Cuban food you don't do what he says
Joe tell him tell him about what's your
favorite meal that you want show a
picture show them the video okay and no
time I will kick I see no gives me shout
outs while he's fighting it
Jordan Wales I don't know what the [ __ ]
this name is he Eric Thompson my man
bobble Lingus Chris Bardwell Christopher
Walford Joe will let BJJ and below
average Joe I love you [ __ ]
always show me what you want okay get it
somebody though I didn't bother he told
me about this and I tried to move to
Cuba
I said get him whoa up why are we buying
oh my god wait he talked he dreams about
this [ __ ] what he wants Joe this is what
he wants what that's what he wants Joe
it's again well up on Miami so he could
eat that every day play the video I love
this I love this how do you not look at
it man oh
oh man go get AI get some income
homologation you go to Miami
never been oh well you need to go I
won't come back gosh I do what my dad's
a bit boring
believe me look if you're gonna [ __ ] oh
and I told him about pudding what their
button legit when this Allah no one is
going is going let's go we gotta figure
out what the [ __ ] is wrong
what time is up what you need to open
totally I'll look it up oh my god it's
what is it right now see what time she's
open to its 8:37 what time is no clutch
you need to open jokes he's like we had
a Rudy Sarzo on and he wouldn't tell you
told us of opening like what is it
butter in the can in the coffee and then
like your loved one went Dicky I like
afraid yeah I was a wild area idea
really sighs oh that when he came from
Hubert what's your favorite dessert
lungs or maybe told us we know - boy say
the language saving you all right tell
means yeah made coolness maybe I was
like that's no logical design and now
with ice cream yeah ice cream with ice
cream 100 in H I met Ugandan sorry
it just amazes put movies ice cream on
the milk cookies what kind of cookies is
it chocolate chip cookies Jesus Christ
Joe hoc and used to point going around
you need you need me you needed it
Oh color on it you're gonna turn I like
a brother well the whole time yeah she's
just wife yeah yeah Jesus Christ
oh yeah you knit and you put it this in
there [ __ ] we do you are you putting
the Michael Michael in here and after
you need it niku astonish the human
sandwich afterwards no no I did skew my
songs
and is that how you eat when you're
after you weigh in like what
come on man get our music with Jimmy go
[Music]
alright I'm gonna give a shout out to my
people Fuji Fuji sport jeez
Fuji jeez boy I don't even know what it
is if you're a five or an eight-six
you're a fat [ __ ] you're looking for a
gig Fugees the way to go don't forget my
people on it always on it what is it
your honor talk common press in church -
ya know I'll adopt I'll press in church
but let me tell you something I like the
hemp for its protein it's not in there
it's my favorite but I love the Alpha
brain and the shrimp export I'll be
taking those tomorrow morning before I
go to kickboxing cuz I'm gonna die
tomorrow but here I gotta talk to you
people about something I told you the
beginning of the show you go to 66% of
men start losing their hair by 35 when
you start to notice hair loss it's too
late
so you reach out you put your hands on
your head you go how much am I gonna I'm
gonna lose every year from now on what
is this gonna do it's easier to keep the
hair you have that there a place to hey
you've lost man like I said Hannah
Franklin who suffered a ton what he was
young by losing his hair when he tried
all the scams and all this stuff and
nothing works but I'll tell you what for
him calm is a one-stop shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for men
medical grade solutions real doctors
offering you well-known generic
equivalents to name-brand prescriptions
to help you keep your hair not herbal
supplements prescription solutions
backed by science no waiting room no
awkward doctor's visits save hours by
going to for hems comm directly to your
door they get delivered you go you
answer a couple questions there's no
awkward doctor visits the doctor will
review your little form and next thing
you know
reiben to you and then boom directly to
your door listen we spoke with the with
the co-founders is a beautiful company
what we're gonna do is this order now
today my listeners get a free trial
month of everything you need to keep
your hair for five hours right now while
supplies last see the website for for
detail from pull for details it's for
hems dot-com slash Joey again for hems
comm slash Joey if you want to save your
hair this is the way to do it alright
order now my listeners get a trial month
so go to four hems comm slash Joey I
want to take my brother Yoel Romero for
coming on the show all the way in Miami
G I want to thank the [ __ ]
help us sitting here with me and it's
time to go eat [ __ ] I'll see you guys
Wednesday don't forget Albuquerque New
Mexico the fifth and the sixth of the
Santa Ana casino I'll see you
[ __ ] then stay black